oi eu sou apolinário é eu vou falar um
pouco pra vocês é do processo que me fez
estar aqui e do que eu faço né e então e
tem a ver com com empatia e
autodidatismo então eu acho que o o o
que me move assim é prioridade
então eu acho que a curiosidade é um
papel fundamental para tudo
eu acho que quando a gente perde aquela
curiosidade que a gente tinha quando era
criança e passa a simplesmente ver as
coisas e pensar como é que será que isso
funciona é na hora que você pensa como é
que será que isso funciona e não
pesquisa como funciona porque você tem
outras atividades para fazer
eu acho que nessa hora que você acabou
perdendo o o ou a sua criatividade a sua
curiosidade é porque a curiosidade eu
acho que gera a criatividade mas não só
curiosidade eu acho que na hora que você
pergunta por que não você você atinge um
potencial então é foi por isso que
quando eu estive no passado nem com que
o encontro nacional de estudantes de
comunicação e aí teve um negócio que
chamava sai à sunna que era onde os
homens usavam saias em solidariedade é
um rapaz foi morto por um crime de
homofobia ele usava saia e aí é eu usei
esse dia pelo ato
pensei por que não usar saia sempre por
que não então eu não achei uma resposta
então fiquei pensando karue sell aplicar
esse pensamento em vez de pensar pra que
né pra que eu fazer tal coisa eu penso
por que não eu não achava eu posso achar
um monte de coisa que me falou que eu
falar por causa disso mas eu não achar
nada eu vou lá e faço então eu achei que
usando isso como como medida pra pra
fazer as coisas talvez sejam bons
resultados e aí é eu acho que um filho
da curiosidade com o porquê não é o
remix o remix nada mais é do que você
juntar coisas que que já existiam e
pegar mudar um pouquinho do conhecimento
da humanidade inteira gerou né através
de milhares de coisas que a gente usa no
dia-a-dia e transformar uma coisa
diferente
com só um pouquinho da sua contribuição
não é o que o pessoal chamado de
criatividade mas tem tudo a ver com os
criatividade não é criar nada do nado
zero e sim remixar coisas que já tinham
né e aí uma das coisas que eu faço é é
um mix
eu não sei se vocês já viram mas eu
criei um câmbio que chamava para o céu
sem o pau em que o objetivo era um bom
fazer montagens com pessoas tirando foto
com um pau de self e retirando o bastão
da imagem
e aí é viralizou e tal outra coisa que
eu já fiz também é foi durante a copa
das confederações de 2013
é você tinha um gerador de placas então
você conseguia por causa daquela
tradição que deu errado
você conseguia montar sua própria
tradição e enfim cada as pessoas criavam
e viravam - e tal e aí outra coisa que
eu fiz também foi o flap generator que
era também o momento o mesmo princípio
você mudava o passarinho eo cano por uma
coisa que você queria e aí as pessoas
geraram teve mais de um milhão de
acessos
mas eu acho que não é só o remix eu acho
que pro remix existir você tem que ter
acesso a informações e olhe o seu papel
quando você acessa uma informação é
transformar essa informação em
conhecimento então além do da questão da
dessas coisas que eu faço brincando
assim pra ver as pessoas se divertindo
então criava esses sites ou colocar na
internet passava desenvolvendo e
colocava lá só para as pessoas podem às
vezes não dava certo é muito próximos
três funcionários mas tem um monte que
eu fiz que que o pessoal nos oitavos mas
além disso eu acho que você busca juntar
essa curiosidade com porque não pode
gerar coisas importantes então por
exemplo essa matéria do correio e você
pensa custo autopromoção mb e eu fazendo
uma pose bizarra que tem a ver mas foi
por causa do seguinte eu entrei
competindo pela lei de acesso à
informação qualquer pessoa pode entrar
pra perguntar quanto é que custava o o o
custo de produção do almoço da unb então
o aluno paga 2 50 no rio
mas quando o que custa para o mp pagar e
aí a gente descobrir
o que o ele estava pagando r$16 no prato
de comida
e aí eu achei caro né eu fiz um
powerpoint no meu blog sobre isso e
acabou que que teve uma repercussão
muito grande depois do correio foi lá e
fez uma matéria e forçou o mp adiantar
um processo que já ia acontecer de troca
das empresas né
então acho que quando você cria é você
pega o conhecimento e você divulga e
você pega informação e divulga você tem
a sua moeda em conhecimento também e aí
é tudo isso é é aliado a uma coisa muito
importante que eu acho que é a
multidisciplinaridade porque eu acredito
que quando você junta várias áreas do
conhecimento você atinge esse potencial
de conseguir levar mais mensagem para
mais pessoas a juntar mais gente
construir mais coisas
então é uma coisa que eu acho também é
que justamente você não se fechar no
curso que você faz na área profissional
que você tá você buscar sempre novidade
e não parar no meio do caminho é você se
atualizar não só dentro da sua área mas
fora então um exemplo clássico que a
gente usa todo dia é a internet né então
por exemplo a web a web é uma é uma rede
que envolve todas essas áreas matemática
ciência da computação engenharia web é a
inteligência artificial economia direito
mídia toda a questão sócio cultural
psicologia biologia sociologia ecologia
então tudo está dentro do do nosso lado
nosso tablet do computador que a gente
acerta todo dia é muito interessante a
gente conhecer um pouco mais de cada uma
dessas coisas né
e aí é bom e aí vai até agora eu falei
um monte de coisas falam beleza mas o
que isso tem a ver com empatia e com e
com alta de batismo é que é o título da
palestra
então eu vou tentar começar agora a
juntar tudo que eu falei pra chegar
nisso aí
então eu acho que uma fonte de
aprendizado muito importante é discutir
com as pessoas mas não discutir
é do jeito do jeito para tradicional que
é hoje em dia é
né é você na internet um fórum e ficar
bolado colocar alguém escreveu e vai
raivosamente é discutir e brigar com a
pessoa e tal e aí você você acaba saindo
com raiva pessoa sai com raiva ninguém
mudou de idéia
você bloqueia aquela pessoa então nunca
mais vai ver o que ela opina sobre
aquilo então uma coisa quer para as
pessoas trocarem experiência acaba sendo
o contrário você acaba se distanciando
de novas idéias e fechando mais ao seu
alcance o que você já acredita né então
é aí alguém tem que ganhar
a discussão na nossa comunicação
tradicional
alguém ganha essa discussão eu acho que
quando se discute dessa forma você não
você não acaba aprendendo nada você
tenta forçar o seu ponto de vista e
acabam aprendendo e é por isso que o
existem outras formas de argumentação
então o psicólogo humanista com lojas
ele criou é essa essa uma nova abordagem
pra gente conseguir é discutir talvez de
uma forma que você gera conhecimento é
para as duas pistas para as duas partes
mesmo se elas descuidarem então é
basicamente é a discussão roseana que é
a tradução para o português seria o
seguinte você é você descreve o seu
problema ou então o o hotel já chega num
consenso de qual é o problema porque
seus duas pessoas tiverem discutindo
coisas distintas
você nunca vai chegar a lugar nenhum
você analisa e aí essa é a partir da
empatia você se coloca no lugar da
pessoa ea analisa quais contexto talvez
o ponto daquela pessoa pode ser válido
talvez não seja no seu
talvez você discorda absolutamente mas
tenta entender por que ela acredita
naquilo que como aquilo pode ser válido
para aquela pessoa
e aí depois você analisa o contexto no
qual o seu ponto vale os mesmos acredita
no negócio mas não reflete muito porque
você acha que está certo então você
analisa o contexto do que o seu ponto
pode ser válido e aí o quarto ponto que
é o maior existe empatia de todos e e
o que chega faz os dois chegarem a um
consenso na discussão é justamente o que
você levar para outra pessoa
os benefícios ao outro lado se o céu é o
meu ponto de vista correto então quando
eu tô argumentando discutindo com alguém
na hora que eu fiz exercício de empatia
de analisar o ponto dele eu falar ó
escola do meu ponto de vista mas sim o
que eu acredito que a minha parte é
certo para o que você acredita a gente
consegue é sss benefícios dessa forma
você gerou um consenso porque a outra
pessoa fizer a mesma coisa os dois
saíram ganhando uma ideia nova um
conceito novo do que o outro é acabou
aprendendo então dessa forma você acaba
gerando mais conhecimento gerando mais
empatia então é pra isso é gente chega
na alta de estatismo então o
autodidatismo nada mais é do que você
aprender não sozinho obviamente porque
você usou é você fazer um remix do
aprendizado né
é você pegar tudo que alguém já escreveu
e fez sobre educação e a colocar um
pouquinho dentro da sua cabeça né então
é eu aí eu acho que lugares importantes
para a gente aprender é discutindo com
as pessoas dessa forma diferente você
aprende muito quando você discute com
cada pessoa conversa com cada um tenta
entender os pontos de vista de cada
pessoa é outro outro jeito cursos online
hoje em dia a gente está na era da de
poder ter acesso a todo esse tipo de
informação e de conhecimento de um jeito
que talvez nunca tenha sido o possível
antes né então a gente tem milhares
dezenas de milhares de conteúdos e
cursos gratuitos na internet legendados
em português sobre todas as áreas e eu
acho que qualquer um consegue aprender
qualquer coisa e então por exemplo mesmo
comecei eu devia ter feito mais mas eu
comecei o curso oratória para me
apresentar aqui então online
então eu acho que dá pra aprender várias
coisas e tem muitos canais do youtube
interessa
na educação e em outro ponto importante
é quando você consegue juntar aquele
argumento ruggeri ano com o estudo que é
justamente na hora que você tenta fazer
a mesma coisa com o autor então na hora
você está lendo um livro você como você
pode tentar dialogar com o autor da
mesma forma que você discutiria com
alguém então você entende ponto de vista
do autor o contexto que ele escreveu
aquela obra coloca o seu ponto de vista
e gera esse e tenta gerar e se esse novo
conhecimento bom e aí por fim é uma
técnica que eu uso pra pra aprender e e
e pode ser útil
chama a técnica pomodoro que basicamente
significa você colocar um tempo de 20 e
25 minutos mas é um tempo que você
coloca e você estuda você estuda esse
tempo tira um intervalo de alguns
minutos
isto de novo então nessa hora que a
gente está querendo ficar o tempo todo
conectado é fundamental a gente poder
estudar ou 25 minutos foi lá no facebook
respondeu três pessoas voltou e ao final
de 4 ao final de quatro pomodoro você
tira um descanso maior para tomar água
vai no banheiro é essa é a forma que um
estudo que eu tenho de aprender e
trabalhar também e é isso